what do you how how do you boys feel
about clubbing
and because i've not been to a club in
japan before
yeah i've been to a few but i've never
enjoyed clubbing even even back in
australia it was just never really a
thing yeah
i like bars but i don't like i really
like bars but i don't like
i feel like okay here's here's my theory
i feel like clubbing
is this place that everyone's convinced
themselves they enjoy when they really
don't enjoy
like it's clubbing is one massive lie i
don't know anyone who actually enjoys
clubbing
because the only time you enjoy clubbing
is if you're massively plastic if you
actually enjoy clubbing
you're someone i don't want to talk to
the people the people i know who enjoy
clubbing are not me the ones who i just
don't like hanging out with yeah yeah i
know i'm not gonna
like the epitome of oh my god they
always talk like
it's like clubbing is like clubbing is
great when you're like young i guess but
then
you you reach a certain point like a few
years past and you realize
man i'd never really enjoy clubbing
isn't it i was just lying to myself
all i do when i go to a club is go in
see the dance floor order a drink go
go dancing for like five minutes realize
i'm still too sober go order another
drink
and then that cycle repeats until you're
[ __ ] drunk enough to not remember the
night
and if you do remember the night it's a
[ __ ] night yeah right and it hurts
because like you gotta pay entry fee
yeah and then you gotta pay like double
the price for a drink so if you're not
drunk enough it's like [ __ ] not only am
i
my am i having a [ __ ] time my wallet is
taking a financial
beating clubs are fast man they're alive
i'll tell you the only times clubbing is
fun but
can i tell the story about the last time
we went club sure sure go ahead
okay i feel like the only time clubbing
is actually fun
is when the night isn't planned when
when you when you don't plan to go to a
club i feel like like the spontaneous
clubbing nights are the best because
you're already
really drunk and in the mood when when
you just suddenly decide to go to a club
so the last time i've actually went
clubbing was like over a year ago yeah
with uh and it was with connor and two
of my mates right
and it was just a spontaneous kind of
clubbing night where we didn't even plan
to go clubbing we just wanted to go hit
up some bars
and then we got massively i think we
were just sitting at your house and we
were just gonna do that
and yeah i think someone brought it up
and like clubbing
i i i i think the i think we were we
were like we were sitting in the house
and we were just gonna have
like a chilled night right we were
telling stories about climbing we were
telling stories about clubbing and i
think eventually we were like should we
just
go clubbing yeah because i remember we
hit up a bar beforehand and
we were like pretty we were pretty uh we
were pretty merry at that point we
weren't super drunk
and then we got to the bar i think it
was like absolute like absolutely vodka
in brighton or something
and we just ordered like three of those
14 shot trays oh my god and
we got drunk very very fast but the
person who got
drunk the most was this guy i think i
had like one of the whole like 14 shots
to myself and
like bear in mind i think i was just i i
[Music]
at the time i just like broke up with my
ex and i was like i just want to go out
i just want to come here
i just want to do something i want to
get out of here it happens yeah i was
like i almost want to party and then i
went i went away
so what was the last memory you had of
that night i remember waiting in line
for the
club alcohol abuse is bad by the way
yeah
we don't condone this this this is a
story not condoning we're laughing about
it
i've rarely do i get that drunk where i
don't remember exactly what happened
which is which i when i speak to
americans like that sounds scary i'm
like yeah
yeah i mean i'm around my mates you know
they'll take care of me so after the bar
we clearly realized how drunk connor was
but we still it was still like pretty
early in the night it was like
it was like 10 o'clock 10 30. the club
had just opened but that's
that's kind of the timing we're talking
about we're just kind of we're all like
okay
before the alcohol gets connor anymore
we gotta [ __ ] get in this club as
soon as possible
so we line up just as the club was
opening it's like a [ __ ] wednesday or
something
yeah yeah no one was clubbing no one
it was like us we were worried about how
connor was going to get in because he
was clearly over the [ __ ] limit and
if you know uk clubs if you look like
you're too drunk i'll be fine they're
just not going to let you win bounces
bouncers in uk are like the but the
school bully like yeah
they're like they will take advantage of
any power they have
so we're [ __ ] worried so somehow
conor we managed to get connor in this
club
okay this is the best heist movie yeah
yeah so we managed to get connected
we're like oh
that's this is it we've done it we've
been we've been impossible we've done
mission impossible
yeah yeah so then we go over to the bar
as you do in the clubbing experience the
first thing you go to
is the bar of course and then we go to
order our drinks and so i'm here with
two of my mates
and we we each order a drink and then we
look around
and connor's just not there we're like
wait if you're not with connor
and you're not with connor and i'm not
with connor
then where the [ __ ] connor and then we
turn around
and look at this like look at this empty
dance floor
right and connor is just standing there
at a 90 degree angle he's like this
and then we're like oh [ __ ] we better
get him off the dance floor and then
like as we're walking over
he starts [ __ ] fortnite dancing by
himself
on the dance floor
and so the bouncer sees this and
obviously connor's like way over the
limit so
he gets kicked out and so we we also we
also have to follow him out the club so
we're like
do we attempt another club it's only
like 10 30. let's try and attempt
another club
thinking we're not going to get in
somehow connor by pure instinct
he's like he's like he can't even walk
to this next club but as soon as he's
standing in line he's like
yes gentlemen i don't know i don't know
why when i'm drunk for some reason i can
just like for like
30 seconds i could be like yes of course
yes i don't know why like it's a
superpower
yeah like when you're when he's in front
of the bouncer he just turns into like
proper sea dog va yeah the monkey brain
unlocks into human brain so then we
somehow
we somehow get him to get him into the
second club okay
and the same [ __ ] thing happens again
we go to the bar
and then we take our eyes off corner for
one second order i drink
i look around look to my look to my left
look to my right
if you're not with god we won't know
we've got
and then we turn around and once again
connor on an empty dance floor is just
fortnite dancing by himself is that just
like an instinct
for you to do like so i think it must be
i like dancing i don't know why fortnite
dancing must be my go-to
i don't know and so we get kicked out of
that club and that was the end of the
night oh my god
uh good night it's good night good night
yeah he he woke up don't get that drunk
yeah he uh he we got him back home uh i
took him on the bed and he just started
snuggling inside the saggy pillow
and yeah that's what he woke up all
these things are getting unlocked
yeah i woke up and i was like where is
my phone and wallet where is it and then
it was just under the bed but i was like
that's like the first five minute panic
of my i was like where is it
oh my god so you don't remember any of
that i remember some of it but not much
yeah i mean that was probably the most
drunk i've gotten in a very long time i
rarely ever get that drunk
yeah but you know sometimes you [ __ ] up
and do a lot of vodka and uh
what happens man because like you've
you've been clubbing in japan
right yeah yeah what's that like how
does it compare to the rest of the world
it's just like at least compared to the
uk right in the uk i feel like everyone
in the club is very drunk and in japan i
felt like everyone was in the same
situation of
i need to be drunker which makes a
really shitty club environment because
everyone's kind of sober and it's weird
yeah no one wants like step out of line
yeah it's weird like no one's doing
anything fun
except like for somehow everyone is
really well behaved
and somehow the moment you step into the
toilet it was like a war zone in that
toilet i don't know what happened
there was a dude who was like pissing
and he was not even aiming in the urinal
he was aiming at the wall next to it and
it was
spraying and i remember walked in and
i'm like i'm not getting blamed for this
i'm walking
because i know this guy was japanese and
i'm like i'm not [ __ ] with it
i don't want to be blamed for this i'm
not doing it i'm the minority i'm like
i'm the foreigner here i'm not getting
i'm walking out right now yeah but yeah
there it was so filthy but the rest of
the club was just like
fine it was whatever it was just a
depressing
situation you know i'd rather have been
smashed fortnite dancing alone
yeah yeah that's that's kind of a
similar experience i had i went to one
club in japan and that was enough for me
to be like
yeah i mean i never really enjoyed clubs
but i was like you know what i'm
living here i might as well give it a go
yeah i just wasn't it
i felt like everyone was doing it
because they've seen it in the movies
there i don't know why
everyone's like this is cool right yeah
right now right like
we've seen this in the movies right this
is exactly how we're supposed to behave
right because i i think the like the
most different clubbing experience
i've had is probably in thailand but
they have like
i i don't like i like their clubbing
culture even less
right because they don't even have a
dance floor so some clubs in thailand
um it's you go in and there's no dance
floor but everyone has their own tables
but the music is just as loud as any
other club
so try and say so you're sitting in a
loud restaurant this is a loud bar right
so you're sitting you're sitting
everyone has these private tables so you
can't even like it's not a social
environment where you can go
meet other people or even like like
interact with other people
you're with your mates but it's so loud
that you can't communicate with your
mates
so all you're doing is sitting in this
loud [ __ ] room i must sound like such
an
old guy now the music was too loud this
was awful but no
no too fair when the music is too loud
it's like my biggest pet peeve yeah like
i'm just like
i've been in some clubs in australia
where the bass is so
[ __ ] bass boosted that you can
actually feel your chest going
dude it's like this is why you're
sitting there i was like hey how are you
my voice is so bassy as well that in
clubs like i could just cannot
communicate
like it just gets drowned i remember
like university if i ever try to like
hit on someone
they'd just be like what are you saying
do you have that thing where you're
trying to say something to your mate but
it's so loud
so you sue or your mate's trying to say
something to you and it just sounds like
and you're like uh sorry can you say
that again you do you do it like three
times is the magic number
and then the third time you're like oh
yeah yeah yeah definitely
yeah i'd be like yeah i don't know i
don't know
whatever they say that's just yeah
that's just the clubbing experience